todas las miradas estarán puestas en
Francia en el verano de 2024 donde se
organizarán los Juegos Olímpicos en el
suburbio parisino de San Denisse está
construyendo un nuevo centro acuático y
una Villa Olímpica que ofrecen multitud
de oportunidades a los demandantes de
empleo y a las empresas pequeñas
al inicio del proyecto nunca hubiéramos
imaginado lo que encontraríamos aquí es
un gran reto porque trabajar para los
juegos no es algo que se haga todos los
días
en este estadio olímpico trabajan varios
sectores diferentes una oportunidad para
que las empresas locales formen parte de
este proyecto colosal
lo que vemos aquí son los dos primeros
asientos empezamos la producción en
serie hace unas semanas y tenemos que
imaginar los otros 2.998 asientos que
habrá en toda la tribuna
a solo 15 minutos de distancia esta
fábrica transforma materiales reciclados
en nuevos productos un punto ventajoso
para conseguir el contrato
El Punto de partida es la recolección de
etapas por toda Francia estas tapas se
clasifican por colores y se reducen a
virutas Aquí vemos las amarillas y las
azules estas virutas se envían a la
máquina Donde se convierten en paneles
100% reciclados y reciclables
para garantizar la puntualidad de las
entregas la fábrica funciona día y noche
para este proyecto se contrató a cinco
empleados a corto plazo como sacaría y
touret
[Música]
nos damos cuenta de lo grande que se
está haciendo la empresa es una buena
noticia y creo que por eso me
contrataron me hace muy feliz estoy muy
orgulloso de estar aquí
varias empresas pequeñas han asociado
para fabricar estos asientos a pocos
kilómetros otra empresa corta y da forma
a los asientos tres mil en blanco nueve
mil en negro gracias a esta iniciativa
diferentes empresas trabajan juntas lo
que les permite ampliar sus actividades
[Música]
buen tema para una empresa pequeña el
objetivo es industrializar estos
procesos la compra pública también nos
permite crear nuevas asociaciones esto
significa que puede acceder a nuevos
mercados absolutamente no podemos
contártelo todo hoy pero ya estamos
trabajando en nuevos proyectos y creo
que revisaremos regularmente este
material en diferentes situaciones
hasta la fecha casi el 40% de los
contratos ya formalizados se han
adjudicado a pequeñas y medianas
empresas
en los proyectos Olímpicos trabajan
cerca de 1500 empresas proceden de 85
departamentos diferentes de modo que
toda Francia trabaja hoy aquí
la villa de los atletas acogerá 14.500
personas tanto atletas como personal
después de los juegos las zonas se
convertirá en un barrio Residencial para
su colorida fachada se están fabricando
unos 500.000 azulejos de cerámica
Esta es la arcilla que acaban de extraer
cerca de la fábrica
para esta empresa Familiar El desafío
consiste en trabajar con diseños únicos
Y darles vida
los arquitectos de los juegos nos
pidieron que fabricáramos este producto
placas curvas triangulares y onduladas
fue muy complicado fabricarlo porque
tenía estas delgadas particiones estoy
orgulloso de que a partir de un dibujo
hayamos conseguido fabricar productos a
medida
el siguiente reto es mezclar los colores
adecuados para conseguir el tinte
perfecto una tarea para Adrián
he tardado dos meses en completar toda
la solicitud Normalmente se tarda una
semana para cinco colores
han sido necesarios cuatro años de
preparación para conseguir un contrato
de casi 400.000 euros una gran ventaja
para el crecimiento de su negocio este
contrato nos ha permitido desarrollar
nuestras capacidades Además nos ha
permitido contratar personal y tener más
visibilidad en total se adjudicaron
contratos por valor de más de 500
millones de euros a pequeñas y medianas
empresas para los juegos olímpicos